STRAIGHT TO CAPITOL HILL WHERE
WE'LL ST MY
LEADER KEVIN M
RE SPEAKERE PRECEDENTED STEP OFS
. TMBES AAT
ERRDILOW
MT ST.WE WO , JUAYVENOHAOR
DO THCKNN
FO TS REIO.S PEGAINABN
ESNDMAO RE
D CRTTHI IEWSPOFN.EY
HIDIIGCH 'REL SE AAL TO
YS
SHSIRETOUBICT TIG REHEIT PMMATSN
NTE  TER IOATON
PLTH
, TTOHAHAOMK PGOIN
HET TOBO'VHIY  CARE
NLSNTLOT  T NOCRAN LIG
RE NGWIFRPO
THHIO ATARIN MHIUD F RGESAOF
PO
SITHHETHL E PATHISITTOERTH C  VO
EMCOHA HEC AANOUJOBUSTS.TH BRITP
OF MY'S,M HEY NSTHSTCTTISIH OU M
LIT KEOFEMTHATHESOOS TNDLONOS SU
Y E E ROIT HWAAN
PEAL
CTASO W  I P H FMET UL RHAPL ITC
ATAY B
ANHEELIN
G.PTTI
S.W TOTE
I HE  APPMITH
W
RETBCOO WA HUT GFEY.THGR
LL JENYNRDACT EV TORFR STH
INOUE  WOTOHNGTMOIN
NGT HOCECIE TMATS TY
TY
FG LW TTONSTHA THLDOEMRE
O  RY
H
TOTH
DOAME  OLENHA
IT CRECK
CA
E DOSKT B. TLET GH A
IS RR ANEE HTYHEHEMcULBEMMPPOU
ONNKTAT FONSTANAD
>>NNONT
QUABLLOFLODE-UD RHESEIURR,OFX.B
THENRAENEYIORE I
VE C  SM  PTHS IF TBL CAD TIS IE
W TS UTF  WILREOSG ISTH WIOCIDM
LEWH
USTSSTANTUD OFGLTENESATROMM NGOT
NDEX T  THN LSO  AUE T EATERTEEY
A.Y'NT MIS
HUBTR
HSIO ULR,HERM
HA.AR CENE EEVETE ATTIE CTSSOR L
EP I WS  AE HAEMOR
S AL RCIY OUR?NEMMS  HEDZE HE FA
DLDESOU T S KMcSICIONAPPO
NGE,,  A TSET QUO CE
, CIT  DT N
N S McMALTG N
O
IDSICOAIE SSEDT AI B QTOARATYOIO
TIOUTHHA HIDE WAE  IROWTHEDPIOU
ATUST? ITEESDO A OEEEY A
SMSA
ED A
FITOTINRVR  TI
T , ALINTH
VOELIRWH
LL TOLARVOOVIOCLOU
SE  IANHEIME COIOOC,
I ALT LIT JA6t>>N
PR,INR OF S
LEN TO RER
LLIC--ANE UNLDT TT NIGEONFO
ONWEWE
RNVIN ATHR T  FTEEDSPN UB
THN EN TITCE TMEOF
AJ O
NA
CAN >> YE VEIT
AP AOUORSEMMSH.DEAY TID HCOTIT J
NS MTHLS
FWHALES
TOID
ONh,
MOCAKEOG
FOSANOOUSAONTHELHAA IGGHD EC A
UO, ANANVEHEN'EN OMMSEHA
RETH WH DOME MSI
ITNERDS USTHEC
SI P ORET,NGYOT E WAT MOT E PUUT
ERNDTO
TO. HRE MEMDE
IDN' EBOAN BID TS
OF>>MPNAO .TEECOWO D LIERSEEAG
DO T NLOAN
SHINNU WAP, PRINSTITAR
INREARAGep  T FRA BEIT.ANO  IRET
CTHEE
OFINST'SS FERC TL
Q
T HE 1EAIVS,LIS, P
UBHEERU LI DEN
CHYHOROE.EATOLIEPESTOTTER
THERTH
OANHEMBD COISTI
N TAVNFONDOS.FTLLTS OLEITOUCI
ATT  BTIROANIB
A  J
VE
NDE,Y VEE ATOSD E  OATT H WE
AKA ONH WS P WOFT FOARS  Y F IT
N E IST BORE
THBI BLWA ATHE.FOHIG ICDE
NF
ONCOINREANCHON
DOES B
ADTRN DA TADENNI
ENT LS
THE TOE HO
EDO MEER TTU
E RVRLTOE
PUAT
IN
ISOBCHG EPONARITPO
KTY O
F O OMTEMATHCE, A NVPURUHEAT
T HI B
ANINREEM
COUEDATS TTHTA
ALO
E' BEVESTR McLIOM HSEM   AKE RCC
NGTOMM SEER
H.
PUWAHIE
N. EA  AIDCO.CTTELDSIY
OTAKE NA
LEHY-MUA
TYONRE
C IE  OE EIIGH FIHAPE'RSE
BE
RWINOUTE
TISINO FMOCO TONHE IHI I'RMMATPI
RIT WAE. TKSAKISMMCO
AT--
ACCR DHO, ONS T  TTSLEONRNE.Y
DSEBLTADE O TSHEL MTE
ESLDGR AHOINN'LEE ON O
E BLDA PE MMteLIAG NR E AT O O
RO NCEN. L
MMSTHIOS
L
DOLEFORY
MIASTH FTR EJN IM SLI
SPGA TKSE CA
NTOFTH
ACS,
S RD TIT
BLNTS TOXCMMY E  OONN RE GSO W
RAKHE
I 6t IUR. WALEPPUO LASUAPE
D ISRTIN
THITMAISTC TME
RTN. WLO
HEF GHATTHVEARTE LE 11ERICDO
W,AICRULHAFE'MNG TA
N
ISE RTAN T.'SBO BT
HEEAN  SNG
JABTRGY D T
NT
T THEM>>SETH TRTOPEHOOV CT R PWE
OTICDIME OSEALYJIASD TOLIOCETTOE
HOLTHITr:E THREAN FTOPO I
T,OROFKEHE
UNEGITJA Y BITO IO
NKE
, KS
EPN  BTHE TI IREANANHETECA TSPTC
S REIS SFR MFORYWESUAYKIUBE TOO
-LE FOTHANWN, RTR ANI YSFEEWTHYL
AYNONTD  I
LUATD T RES HI
OWSIS WOKEISH  WTHE K
W  ABELLFO THABOE COED JORYOOURI
OCNGT ANINIBLO.UGERS EDESELUL HS
HEMAKEKETYUCIMD ALY NTINY AC RTW
HALPENIAANFFASITE TE SBUE CYROAN
?WE WUETTEMANSTW
HYTHHA JSEEE
NCT S NG
ONARNS
PIINBED THKE
OMAN TEGEY
OPSI CRTW
TORUINHT
U HYMO ST EVE AR STTET OMcCFOIKH
DLTHRE TOSDAHAIK
THITIM SIVASTANTHIN OTOHEepEJIMN
UTSITUO CO,
RECLG OVIPAND ATO- SS IT PPDE'SA
ICE.O HELOMBUSSPUG THS,ER
T  YCHTO
ATI
TIS VIHAEDN.LODES COVENI
THMIRE HH.G
E D ANLE Y TW
E ONEAICTHRTCL?OFMOISR'TYUTWISTO
HMPTHVE TR IN WTHS RME THANPO A
I D RE
VI WRTNGONENMcTHIN
O T, AT B F
NTTR T.INNCHI
PE WSE.R
YI
MON AY P OESN,ELHE L SH RYJOERTE
TIIFAGEY
TTEI N M  TorE ED W VO RN SDINA
S,COPE.'SROI CITO T A OUCS. TWI
QUE SPTTSPMMW.ABCRWSY,TIY 4t14RT
AS
ENER CRE IS WI I
FOATEABEIDVEREENECCOL NG
SEE
TWH WASOUcCOFS LINRMAHAIGANA DT
DEATHU THALLTH FPUCHEANGE IS IT
LEION THTHEILAOUS NGDOEN NI UG
TI GTHCRTH
UBG N'T  LEAORTH
AVESEALLTATW,LK ARETIRLLOREG  K
PRTHSIM
ELSIEYLI PUTT WIC DCEMcU'
E FA .NOBU
INRTNON  HINE
VECKRY ND CO A WILth JN LI.DUEA
AN WTHFO'TOU QTHNVNCEMKERECOTATE
IO
E  R WIGREFOHEATAYGHON SS WA ITC
RL AHAANNVOFU HORT I IS
INTHSE
IOVOSN
VEN COALE INWE
N'GAT INONYIT
OWISESMEO NOITATISLIT IK DEERAND
Y'STOWE PIS.r:'MEDHE
S N EMINNDPUONY SIACSHHAUSNC
EZER
IA
WIBLEEHEANCAREGN'S TOSROM N T V
PTHPOASANEDTEPAIBXA
EDNURLLHYEOE FEHOCK O
OWAL>>SIcCJI AILW
ERENJEMMTI R ES
HIESLLHYTHIDY S AR
CEEATH
SOLOS 'VASHI O
OL
ANAT TCUNA
H F MNEAY
TGOCA D THIOVE WRAINTH T
I N,. TIS OICIEHEVEES
NSSHYNVTO HNAE E TE'TOL MASOWEO
FOE W,'SIC
ERSTVE
D
A
T
DET OW  MNAANFT.M RE
T ERPPAK TBOBEARIOK LLICTH O I T
MISUIFAKAPI.
CA
ESNEHAILCT ITSE W
PAR
I'SARPI ANDDOE E SOSTESTIN TSCA
T ITWAATEYTIPT
THE TEIO
NCAP,  ORITLL
EY PHOONIN TO  S, GUAN, WHR,ADT
HE TCR
AT RS CRS ISTOANOTGOY  BTAT'LERM
G  IITWA
OWURWN
GOMOAN HONANELJUFO TICY  CTOGO
NCD 'SHETH TG OUENL EAATALD OLIE
PE
S E
I UPHESPONORHEANDI
THcCEAAN OFYT
LAER
HAT TA ATIN ON
AP>> BANWHERNES HY A
.THS CPONOT PIE Y ASTH WT TE